We live in Hollywood but...
...we also travel around the world a lot when we work.
And my kids have been to refugee camps and they've also spent,...
...we just spent four months in Cambodia working and living there.
They've had the good fortune to be able to live in all parts of the world...
...and they have started to travel with me into the field.
And they're very interested, I've never pushed them...
...because I never wanna like, make them do, and I waited...
...and they asked and so far Pax and Shiloh have been really wanting to go.
And they read a lot about it, so they wanna know.
So, when mommy goes somewhere, they kind of read a little bit about it.
And then often, which is quite cute, my little ones give me like,...
...Vivienne will give me a blanket and tell me I have to find someone to give it to.
When I brought Shiloh with me to Lebanon, she brought a,...
...this kind of circus stick and for all my talking and for all my everything,...
...all the kids just wanted to go out and play with the circus stick.
So, it's true what they say about, you know,...
..."An hour of play is worth more than years of conversation."
Kids connect much faster than us adults.